Okay, so we have been asked when will this instruction commit. We already know
that this one will broadcast the result in cycle 16, that means it cannot
commit in the next cycle. So, basically in cycle 15 we have committed this,
in cycle 16 we cannot commit this because the broadcast is happening in 16,
we can only commit it at 17. Next cycle 18, we will check if this can commit.
Yes it can because it has already broadcasted its result and it's done.
And finally this becomes 19. So the correct answer here is 19.
You can see that, to determine this we didn't actually have to figure out what
really happens here. But let's do that for the sake of exercise. So in cycle 17,
this gets marked down. 32 gets deposited in register 1. We check the mapping for
R1. Is it ROB4, no. We leave the RAT alone, and free this ROB entry.
In cycle 18, we can commit this. We put minus 1 in R4. We check the entry for
R4. Is it pointing to ROB5? It is. We changed the RAT to point to this R4 and
we free the ROB entry. And finally in cycle 19, we commit this instruction,
we put the value of R3 into R1, we then check the ROB entry for
R1, is it pointing to ROB6? Yes it is. Make it point to here, and
we can free this ROB entry. And this concludes really what happens,
in this whole program as far as, you know, cycles one through 19 are concerned.